carl jung
is really quite radically different in
his approach to the psyche
than than other
models of psychology as you may know if
you've had a chance to study young
in recent years there's been a lot of
pressure
in in jungian circles
to try to sort of
sort of reduce the sense of differences
between
young psychology and other schools of
psychoanalytic thought
i am not one of those who
who feel that that's the way to go for
the future of young psychology
and so i want to be speaking tonight
about what i think is uh
our key key uh
assumptions upon which jung's you young
works
and uh and uh the way that we
can be thinking about uh carrying those
forward what we're looking at here
is uh an image of the axis mundi
now
in in mythical traditions and spiritual
traditions throughout the world
there was always a sense and i refer you
to the work of merchant iliadi
the great historian and phenomenologist
of religion who was the person
the single person who has done the most
uh in the study of world spiritual
traditions
to to point to the role
in world spirituality
of a sense of a center out there
a center i like to say with the capital
c
uh the quest for the center out there
is at the heart of world spiritual
traditions
and in young psychology
uh unlike any other psychology
there is a sense of a
center beyond the ego
for jung there is not simply
one center in the personality
the i there's not simply the i
so many psychologies today emphasize
the uh what we used to call ego
psychology they've got different labels
now but almost all of them
uh focus on trying to help
build the ego of the personality and to
to strengthen the eye of the personality
in relating to the various
challenges of of human life
jung psychology has from the very
beginning
and i think it is a fundamental uh
assumption
is that there are two centers
uh in the psyche uh one
has to be developed uh that is
the ego the capacity
to have a stable sense of i
but the archetypal self which we're
addressing tonight
is a is scene was seen by jung as a
center beyond
the eye and jung's quest
for for his entire career was to
come to an understanding of the
the the role of the self in human life
the archetypal self
uh and to understand the importance of
the the i coming to relate
to the to the archetypal self
a organizing center in the personality
we could say
two things that the archetypal self
isn't is an organizing center
that contains uh
a blueprint a
a primordial image of wholeness
and of integration in the psyche
and another thing that often is not
emphasized as much as it should be but
it was implicit in jung's work
is that the archetypal self the center
outside of the eye in the psyche
was an enormous energy generator
and so we'll be thinking about
the those different aspects of the self
this evening
but one of the things that i want to
just put as a frame here is the emphasis
that for young psychology
there is a center outside
the eye now in the ancient world
as jung would put it
people projected that center
out on many different objects
i like to point out that they're project
projected on sacred mountains
uh all over the world i have another uh
presentation in which i
uh show people the various uh
archetypal images of the center out
there
but but in any case the
the center out there is a point
as experienced as a point all the
pilgrimages
that human beings go on are are actually
acting out ritually acting out the
journey
to the center with a capital c so
uh this is this is uh in ancient
religions uh an archetypal projection
of that center out there
now in that center out there
is a lot of there's a lot of imagery
and world spiritual traditions about
the journey to the center and then the
ascent to the center
with the implications that when you go
to the center
there is a that there is a
hierarchy of spiritual development
a hierarchy of development in which
one begins to connect to the center
to connect to the energy that comes in
through the center
and say that the the the energy comes in
on this vertical axis but if
if you've not really connected with the
center then you
you live at the lowest level of human
organization we'll be
seeing how this relates to uh
to the individuation process in a bit
but let's look at it this way now this
is from the book the archetype of
initiation
so at the lowest levels of development
there's a great deal of chaos
experienced
and and there is no sense of orientation
to a center
one one is living in a kind of a
wasteland
at some point however there's a there's
an experience of
an epiphany that is there is there is
there appears
we see it in the mythical traditions
there appears
uh a star in the sky
that tells the magi
the the ones who know that there is a
that there is a direction to go
in to pursue connection
with that center and the one who
represents that center
and so when that epiphany occurs
then the effort is made to move toward
that
center and to begin to get
energy from the connection to the center
and this
in this location here this is when uh
we will be talking later on this is when
you
connect in some way
with a manifestation of the sacred
or as jung would say a connection with
something that you experience
is numinous in your in your life
when you make that connection there's a
there's an energy flow that starts
and that begins to issue in the flow
of creativity uh jung believe
that when you begin to connect
with uh with the archetypal energies of
the psyche
that there will be a flood
of uh energy coming in and
you've all heard the term inflation if
you're if you've been studying young
inflation is when you get a flood of
this archetypal energy
and it begins to uh
fill you up uh fill you up with energy
and and then if you get
really too inflated
with energy you have got to really be
developing some capacity for containment
of that energy and when you
are capable of having a containment of
that energy
then it is better possible it's more
possible for you to be able
to to form relationships
in both fam for both family intimate
relationships and community
and then finally as you mature into
a more generative place you get to the
point where you can really
uh be committed
really fascinated with and interested in
and committed to
generativity in relationship to the
world beyond the
eye so that is that is a
a traditional image of
the developmental process